hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar freeways a great glassware
washer saves you time and money
i am michelle ashton of laberd's and
I'll be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots and brought to
you by Levchenko to learn more about our
sponsor please visit
www.gfi.com/webmonitor in the
presentation to do so simply type them
into the ask a question box and click
send will answer as many questions and
we have time for at the end of the
presentation if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation click on the
support tab found at the top right of
the presentation window or report your
problem by clicking on the ask a
question box located on the far left of
your screen
this presentation is educational and
best offers continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
credits tab located on the top right of
the presentation window and follow the
process to obtain your credit I now
present today's speaker taylor jennings
the product manager at Longo corporation
for the complete bio on our speaker
please visit the biography tab at the
top of your screen taylor you may now
begin your presentation
thank you for that hello everyone my
name is Tyler jigs and I am a product
manager of lap compco and specifically
I'm a product manager of glass for
washing and I want to take a little bit
of your time today to talk to you about
how you could be saving some time and
money by using glass for washer
so for starters what do I mean by
glassware washer so the easiest way I
can think of to explain this to you is
to think of a dishwasher but as you
would have at home a more robust these
dishwashers are more of us and that they
provide flexibility durability and
maximum clean ability that your lab may
need in more details the flexibility
actually comes in to the different sizes
configurations accessories that make
this unit flexible more available to all
different kind of needs that you would
see in your laboratory and it's very
durable because it's constructed of
stainless steel as well as other
materials that withstand harsh chemicals
and other hazards you may see in your
labs and the maximum clean ability is
simply put these units are very very
powerful they can get very very hot up
to 199 degrees Fahrenheit they include
purified water rinses they can generate
steam as well as many other features
that are built to help clean and dry all
glassware you will see that you will see
in your lab and you will use in your
research now I started off by saying
this was a more robust dishwasher but I
want to clarify that it is not a
dishwasher difference between a home
dishwasher and a glassware washer -
simply because the construction of the
unit because this unit is constructed in
a way it can withstand much higher heat
they can withstand the collaboratory
chemicals that you will see it also is
built - and take purified water whereas
your home dishwasher you can only take
the tap water it also has what's it also
has dual pumps and what I mean by this
is that your single gear washer at home
has a single pumps that pump pulls in
the water washes all of your dishes and
that same pump pulls the water out
whereas in a glassware washer there's
two pumps one to pull in the water and
one to expel the water this way you
don't have cross contamination
so who wouldn't need these obviously we
talked about you would mean if you're in
a laboratory but more specifically if
you have glass whether you're going to
reuse if you're paying someone whether
it's a lab tech a student and turn to
watch these glassware if you are
somebody that has standard operating
procedures or you need to validate the
cleanliness your lab or you are a GMP
lab you're currently using a home
dishwasher or even if you're just trying
to save some money or trying to be
eco-friendly or save some water these
are this is a type of unit that you kind
of want to look into for your lab
so the skin's a little bit more of the
details to do the actual what makes this
unit green and what actually saves you
money what is the value proposition of
this product of this type of product
first off is the water conservation so a
basic study you can kind of Google if
you have time is that the average faucet
you would see in your labs uses about
two to three gallons per minute when
it's running and so it's in a standard
lab washing environment usually you can
kind of argue that a student intern
group a lab assistant whoever you're
using will take about 30 seconds to
lather up a piece of glassware and so
rinse it out and put it to on a drying
train so if you did the math for that
that comes up to about if you're using
about 30 pieces of glassware a day that
comes up to about 34 gallons of water
using a day and you can expand that to a
whole year where as you can see my chart
we can get to by eighty-five hundred
gallons of water in a year now in a
glassware washer it's a lot less
glassware washer uses about three to
four gallons of water per fill what I
mean by fulfill is every time the washer
is filling up to run a rent cycle or a
wash cycle that's considered a fill so
per second argument let's say you decide
to do about two rinses and two and two
wash cycles so you can kind of get up to
about say eleven gallons of water a day
that's typical but at the same time you
could also do a lot less so you can do
one rent cycle one wash cycle and have
half this the for sake of argument would
say to wash cycles and to rent cycles so
in this scenario you're using 11 gallons
of water a day and expand it out again
to a year you're using about a fourth of
what you would be using my hand this
says it even includes the fact that in
the first example you had somebody
working in Washington 30 pieces of
glassware
whereas in the glassware washer you
could be washing hundreds of test-tubes
at one time
let's expand this a little bit further
so same examples before but this case
let's talk about the person you have
worked in there so if you typically
speaking I only miss a typically
speaking this was me 15 20 years ago you
getting paid minimum wage to say 725 an
hour and you're doing that same example
30 pieces of glassware 30 seconds at a
time so 15 minutes of your day you're
spinning wash your glassware you work
out all the math by the end of the year
your your lab is spending $450 on this
one employee just washing glassware now
that doesn't include any of the other
lost cost that you have moving this this
student into another project if the
student breaks the glassware this
doesn't include drying this is a lot of
factors this is strictly just just the
fact that you're spending $400 a year on
just having a student wash glassware
you
if you need if you have a more specific
way to look at this we have a link our
website I actually have it here and will
be willing to provide it to you after
this presentation but you can go in
there and you can you can input some
more specific details of your situation
you know this was more of a specific
situation to me but maybe you have
somebody who makes less money more money
maybe your cost of water is different
maybe your you have a protocol in your
lab that your hand-washing and you have
been you require your person to wash it
for a minute at a time whatever it may
be you can go to this website and get
some information kind of get an idea how
much money you're spending a year both
on water and on employee costs on just
hand washing and washing your glassware
some other things that you'll notice is
that the way these units are built kind
of go back to how it's built they're
aluminum back into laced insulated and
fiberglass blanket surrounds this washer
and that is the most notable or the most
common way you see this is that helps it
sound a lot quieter but also it helps
retain the heat inside the washer so
going back to when I said this
Washington gets 199 degrees Fahrenheit
well if you're running multiple rinse
and wash cycles and you want to maintain
that temperature you know it takes a lot
of energy that he paid a washer up to
get to that temperature whereas in a
glassware washer they're built in a way
where they're not losing that much heat
so on new water when the whole water
drains out a new water comes in you're
keeping some of that heat and some of
that energy in order to to reduce the
time you need to heat up your water
another thing is that these glacier
washes are all in one washer and dryer
products and kind of going back to our
example we were talking about a minute
again if you are just hand washing it
you usually have a rack you're going to
dry your glassware with or if you have
some kind of mechanism you're using your
and your lab to wash products maybe you
have something specific for your test
tube something specific for beakers etc
etc whereas a glassful washer is
actually built to accept any kind of
kind of glassware you'll see where
there's volumetric pipets test tubes
beakers volumetric flasks set and at the
same time and also dry so these units
are built as like an under counter unit
someone to what you'd have at home and
it's an only one unit and that you are
saving both your space requirement and
operator needs in your lab another
feature these units tend to have is
what's called a delayed star so the
program and you can program the units to
start at a certain time where as energy
is considered not peak hours what I mean
by that is you can set that you can set
the unit and say hey I wanted to run six
hours from now when I'm home in a room
now some of y'all probably be like oh
absolutely nothing no use to me but some
of y'all might maybe can kind of see a
reason for this
I'll give you an example you probably
move wondering since we started this
conversation where my accent comes from
well I'm from Texas and in Texas during
the summer we actually have a energy
program with a lot of different power
companies where if you any energy use
from 6 p.m. to 6 a.m. is free anything
from 6 a.m. to 6 p.m. is tends to be a
little bit more expensive than normal
but 6 p.m. to 6 a.m. is free so my wife
used to hate me when we went out there
because I had a tendency to never turn
the a/c on until I got home for the day
and in that scenario that's something
that was this kind of a product would
apply to me because if I was setting up
my washer to wash them my product or
wash my glassware from the day's work I
would definitely set it in the day as I
was walking out the door that that's
free energy for me
lastly about the green about being green
we'll talk about is that if your lab is
trying to be LEED accredited our actual
lab can cause actual glassware washers
are mentioned in the lead accreditation
papers so if your lab is trying to be
LEED accredited if you use one of our
glassware washers that is worth a single
point towards your accreditation and
it's written writing their rules of law
so they kind of talking generically
about glass for Washington general but I
would like to take a little bit of time
and just kind of show you all what some
standard features and what's more
specific towards my glass or washers so
if you have any more questions
specifically about my product I can kind
of tell it to you so kind of how we
discussed at the very beginning these
products are built with stainless steel
interior and exterior specifically we
use type 304 that's kind of a standard
in certain labs we talked about the dual
pumps but other things we need to
mention here is that the multiple
electrical configurations so in North
America you have your standard 115 or
208 internationally you have 230 and
then when we get to the frequency levels
and amperage levels there's a lot of
other requirements as well all of those
requirements we can do we have all
availability 208 230 volt single-phase
an hour 15 volt 50 60 Hertz these units
as I discussed before get up to 100 99
degrees Fahrenheit that essentially
exclusive to your 208 230 volt units our
115 volt units will get up to about 180
drying temperatures are a little bit
less that's more to about the 150 160
range depending on what your unit you're
using we do offer both under counter and
freestanding units so under counter once
again think of what you got at home it's
just literally a washer would put under
the counter a free-standing unit is the
exact same product the difference is
I'll have stainless steel sides and back
panels to it that way if you wanted to
put it out and say in the corner of your
lab we're out more in the open it's not
much of an eyesore it looks nice as well
if you're doing that kind of option we
have something called a mobile option
where I can where you can add feet to it
as well as um different aspects that way
you can kind of move it to different
labs if you have if you have a need for
something like that
with all glass River washers accessories
parts and natural products themselves
when it has a lab Conoco there's a
two-year warranty on all of it
so anything breaks or anything needs
replacing we take care of it no
questions asked and we're located in
Kansas City everything is made here
they're fully programmable so your
standard the standard washers are
washers come with 10 preset factory
programs and 2 custom programs so what
that means we have 10 programs that we
have tested and for one reason or
another maybe it's a glass only cycle or
a plastics only cycle these units can be
used for plastic wear as well but we
haven't we have 10 programs that are
preset for what we what we have tested
to work now these programs are slightly
adjustable to whatever your needs may be
at the same time we have two custom user
set programs those are completely up to
you you design you develop them how you
want them and what I mean by how you
develop them is that you have up to two
washes and you can determine the time
and temperature or those washes you have
up to six rinses again time and
temperature the rinses as well as what
kind of water you're feeding it to your
rent cycles whether that's your tap
water or your purified water you can
also program your drive time you can
have no dry at all or you can have a dry
time all the way up to 250 minutes
temperatures again you can have from
room temperature air as well as all the
way up to about 150 160 degrees
Fahrenheit
the two main products that we have want
to bring out we have what's called the
steam scrubber in the flask rubber the
steam scrubber is your standard washer
it's similar to once again somewhat to
what you have a home it comes with two
open racks and open racks or open
because they're designed for you to add
accessories to it to be flexible to what
you're trying to work with in your lab
in other words if you're watching a
bunch of different things say beakers
utensils pots and pans cetera et cetera
you can use one of these rags because
there's different ways you can kind of
customize it to your needs the flash
scrubber is a little bit different it's
a very similar unit the difference is
instead of the to open racks it just has
a lower spindle right now the spindle
rack as you can kind of see in the
picture almost on the screen it has a
poke it has 36 spindles the spindles are
these little posts that have this
glassware holder and what it is it is
designed for narrow neck glassware
specifically it's designed to wash rinse
and dry the inside of a narrow neck say
Erlenmeyer flask or a volumetric beaker
something something really skinny test
tubes as well but these units come with
36 spindles built on the lower spindle
rack you can add enough for spindle rack
as well as well as you can add upper
rack an upper cut an upper open basket
to this as well and the good news is our
racks are completely interchangeable so
if you have one or the other whether
it's a steam scrubber or flash cover and
over time you decide you wanted that
other kind of rack no problem at all
they install and removed and installed
quite easily saying we also offer what
we call our 33 lines the same product
line the difference is is that it is
designed for ABA compliant american
disabilities Association compliance so
if you need to have if your caseworker
in your labs it's built in a way where
your washers need to be up to 33 inches
or shorter we have the exact same
product it's the same thing as that says
before we just make them that certain
time
as well as if you're in a lab that has a
lot of validation requirements I would
recommend you look into what's called
our Vantage
our Vantage is essentially a flash
scrubber with all the bells and whistles
so a detergent dispenser how it normally
works is once again similar to what you
have at home and that there's a
detergent cup whereas an advantage is
actually an automatic dispenser it
connects directly to your bottle of
detergent and it's protein you program
on the washer how much detergent you
want to use each cycle as well as your
neutralizing acids some people get
confused it relies an acid is similar to
your jet dry you use at home as well as
this unit does come with a few other
features such as a water conductivity
sensor that way you can kind of tell how
clean your water is an rs-232 port that
way you can output your data from your
water your wash cycles to a computer
printer or whatever you may need and
whereas the HEPA filter built into the
airline that way when you're getting the
drying air is actually HEPA filtered
free for this
the targets we can ask a lot of
questions a lot by what kind of
detergents we use so we do offer on
detergents we call them lab solutions
but you do not have to use my detergent
so our detergents and other detergents
the only thing I recommend is that you
get a detergent that is non foaming or
low foaming and the good news is most of
these detergents that will actually say
lavatory washing detergent so get a
laboratory Washington Turgeon that's non
foaming low foaming you'll be good our
acid is once again it's very similar to
a jet dry it's not made for an actual
acid wash what it is is actually
designed to attract to the detergent
polical particles that way it turns down
a little easier
and briefly as I said with the different
rats whatnot we have accessories you can
customize your different your washer
it's more surfaces which is business
more specifically we are units are
flexible to whatever your need may be so
if you're watching a lot watching a lot
of test tubes we had several different
designs for test tubes
you're watching Erlenmeyer flasks
whether it's volumetric pipettes beakers
utensils VOD bottles petri dishes we
have different customizations and
different accessories that you can
purchase that you can add to your washer
for your needs but as always you have
any anything out of the ordinary we
highly recommend you call us and ask us
any questions you may have
sometimes customers call and we'll ask
something they feel is a little bit out
of the ordinary and usually we have a
solution for them we're always helping
to help copy to help at this time I'm
going to take it take a little break and
allow you all to ask any questions you
guys might have I appreciate all
everybody who came to this webinar and I
thank you for your time
Thank You Taylor for your informative
presentation we will now start the live
Q&A portion of the webinar if you have a
question you'd like to ask please do so
now just click on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for now let's get started our
first question is how much water does a
washer use
so typically in our washers it's roughly
about 13 liters a cycle by cycle again
not that means if you're doing one one
wash and one rent cycle that's 26 liters
of water
thank you all right what is the best
rack or accessories to use if I am
washing test tubes you have a couple
options here so if you're primarily
washing test tubes we have what's called
our test tube spindle rack it is very
similar to a spindle rack you would see
on a standard flat scrubber but what it
is is it has a lot of smaller spindles
and holders specifically for test tube
sizes so depending on your size you can
wash wash a couple hundred of test tubes
at one time we do have some other
options if your you have a little bit
larger test tube a lot wider mouth test
tubes we are not so concerned about
trying to get inside the test tube
itself and those are just simple holders
that we can put both on spindle racks
and standard racks depending on what you
need
thank you how
that's my Inlet tap water need to be my
recommendation is you do about 60 see
and really free anybody as long as you
turn it you see you connected to your
hot water tap and you have it actually
coming in as hot as you possibly can the
washer has built-in heaters so it's
going to heat up the water to whatever
you want it to be but keep in mind that
takes time so the hog the water is
coming in the better sees the Y I kind
of say around 60 see
thank you how could we wash large glass
better like 5 to 10 liter volume
capacity speaker conical flask etc
a couple options so you know under
counter models you can take out a top
rack and want and use only the lower
rack specifically in our unit there's
about 19 and a half inches of space in
there and that's kind of roughly around
19 to 20 inches using what you have in
an under counter unit so as long as if I
remember correctly a 10 liter beaker I
think it's about 14 so you can want you
as long as you take a top rack out you
can wash with a lower rack but that can
be a lower standard rack or spindle rack
and you would still have the very top
rotating homer to cover the outside of
the unit as well they do also make much
larger units so if you have if you are
doing hundreds of 10 liter beakers at at
a time
they're much an industrial size washer
or a large capacity washer might be more
of use for you just because they'll have
a little bit more space
great thank you what is the normal
drying temperature of washed glass
where's so twofold answer kind of so
typically speaking if you're talking
about this drying and the laboratory
user just putting on a rack and let it
air dry as for a glassful washer it
similar to how you do it with your wash
programs or water programs it is
programmable my unit specifically is
anywhere between thirty eight C to 70 C
you don't really want to go much much
higher because with with glassware glass
obviously will get a will get hot and
hold it eat a lot longer make it a
little bit more of an annoyance for the
user when I take in the glass out and if
you're washing plastic where you don't
really want it to get much hotter than
that because you're going to damage in
your plastic ware
great thank you and let's see the next
one is how can we be sure that the
glassware is completely clean so this is
another twofold answer we do a lot of
tests and studies on cleanability as
well as inhibit Tillery residue studies
here those studies are you can predict
them they're provided on a website or
you can contact me and I can get them to
you as well as the definition of clean
is kind of dependent on you in a way and
that when we talk about using these kind
of units for validation purposes or a
GMP lab or anything like that
you have some kind of standard in your
lab but what you define is clean then
you're gonna have to figure out what
settings you a need for a washer to get
to that point my recommendation when
somebody comes to me and doesn't know
how to get to that point is use a Mac
cycle on the washer there's one or two
provided for you it's the intense Plus
cycle and that kind of guarantees that
will you run that program it will get
your glass will get clean you'll see
that you'll you'll get clean and then
you can kind of back from there in other
words you can use a few less rinses
lower your temperature until you get to
a happy medium where you're not using as
much energy and water and then you're
also getting your desired results
thank you all right the next one is how
to do clean narrow tub pipettes
automatically so we have a few different
ways for pipette when it comes to the
glassware washers there is actually
accessories you can attach to spindle
racks where you can put pipettes on the
on the spinner racks correctly in a way
and they'll hold them in place in the
Washington clean amount just like you
would with any kind of other narrow neck
glassware for my unit this accessory can
do a max of about 16 pipettes at once
again you do have some height
requirement they this accessory can be
bent at a 45 degree angle to kind of
help with that height requirement but
there is obviously a restriction there I
do also didn't cover in this
presentation but we also do sell a
pipette automatic washer that can wash
up to 64 pipettes
and it does the same kind of technology
as you would see in a standard flat
scrubber and that it percolates the
water and detergent going in to inside
the actual pipette washing it and
rinsing it out anteriorly and then
spraying it out an exterior link to that
way you can wash both internal and
external as well as drying
and I can give you more information on
that if you want I'll give you all my
contact information after this
presentation
thank you all right the next question is
what this is a two-part question what
kind of water do you recommend for
rinses I've heard that if it's too pure
it can damage the washer and does it
depend on the stainless steel quality
that's actually correct so you do not
want to do ultra-pure or typhoon water
in a washer because it is stainless
steel so basic warrant water chemistry
for you guys when you use an ultra pure
water there's no there's nothing in the
water that theoretically there's nothing
in the water that conducts electricity
so the polarity of water swaps and
instead it tries to take in actual
particles so when you put it on
stainless steel you end up actually
itching the stainless steel because the
water essentially eats it so when we say
purified Princes we use this a type 3 or
RO water that's usually more than pure
enough for what you're trying to do and
you won't see any problems with
stainless steel in RO water
great alright what connectivity is
recommended what is the limit um so this
is kind of similar to the cleanability
question and that it is kind of depended
on you there's not really a limit in
this case however if you do have your
tap water is very very hard coming in I
do recommend you get a water softener
um I do recommend you do get a water
softener and they're readily available
pretty cheap you can get one at your
local hardware store and attach it
directly to your line the same time if
you do have hard water you're probably
better off with your rinse cycles do is
in a little bit more purified water but
there's not really a limit in terms of
the units in terms of conductivity if
you do have a conductivity sensor on the
washer it will show you where the
conductivity of the water is coming in
and out just to kind of give you a sense
of what you're washing your glassware
with essentially but there is no limit
to what it can I can't use
you
we have time for one more question on
the mobile models house with the water
drain so a mobile kit actually comes
with a drain pipe that connects directly
to your sink so that is actually
primarily the main thing that people
will do is they'll take they'll take
that drain pipe and connect it directly
to their same drain so to string with
that the sink water
Thank You Taylor do you have any final
comments for our audience I just want to
thank you all for your time and thank
you for listening to me today if you
have any other questions feel free to
contact me we we at lab concur are
always here to help and we enjoy hearing
some of your research and stories so
thank you everyone thank you again
Taylor for your time today and your
important research we would also like to
thank lab roots and our sponsor lab
Congo for underwriting today's
educational webcast before we go I'd
like to thank the audience for joining
us today and for their interesting
questions questions we did not have time
today and those submitted during the
on-demand period will be addressed by
the speaker via the contact information
you provided at the time of registration
lab roots will or even via email when
it's available for replay we encourage
you to share that email with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event until next time goodbye